[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 74
and now for something completely and
entirely different yes indeed we're
gonna go
uh we're gonna go full money python this
time are going electric
what we're going electric it's like when
bob dylan went electric oh
it caused quite quite a stir did it yes
okay i
uh we weren't it was a it was a betrayal
of everything that he stood for
and this is a betrayal was this one was
this
boy i think it was uh just beef boy i
shouldn't have
introduced a topic like that without
having looked it up but it was a thing
yeah okay wow um so here we are
um episode 74 and we are indeed going to
do something
entirely different this time we are
going to
start doing ads and
in support of that we are going to spend
the entire episode
after near the top of the hour here
speaking
ads for two products that we actually
legitimately vouch for
explaining what our position is on
advertising why it is given what our
position is on advertising that we are
now willing to do ads and then we are
going to present to you eight ads of our
own for which we are no way being paid
and in some of those cases
it will be totally clear because the ads
are not actually
pro bono works it's pro bono simple pro
bono works and
simple so we are going to um
uh just in a couple seconds here uh do a
couple of ads for products that
we are now uh being paid to advertise um
but first one just one announcement at
the top of the one correction we'll go
with your announcement and my correction
um we for um for our patreons so we're
working um on a replacement for super
chat
um such that uh we are not as beholden
to youtube
and so that youtube doesn't take the um
35 to 40 percent
of the revenue that we generate uh with
uh with any of the revenue that we
generate with them um so we tried
out uh a a test of the system
several weeks ago and it didn't end up
working but we went ahead and did the
half hour
uh just live stream anyway we called it
wrong answers to bad questions and it
was actually a ton of fun
so we're going to do another one of
those for our patrons only
i think it's going to be this monday at
5 00 p.m
and i haven't posted it on the patreons
yet we will do that um and then once
if once you are a member of our patreon
at five dollar level or above you'll be
able to access that
and you will be able to ask um no no
we'll do it with the chat
right and then i don't know if we're
gonna do wrong answers to bad questions
again or maybe we should do wrong
answers to good questions or good
answers to bad questions
um we should we should talk about any
other ideas achieving greatness for fun
and profit
no no all right that can't be it uh
we'll come up with something
um yes okay what's your correction am i
correct so
we have uh made a policy of doing
corrections on the show when we get
something wrong
it's painful but it's great to get on
the other side of these things
last week i was proposing a solution
to the ever given stuck in the suez
canal and i suggested
a ship full of dried fruit and
cabbage to come in the canal behind the
ship and dislodge it
kind of push it along right no i should
have said
prune juice and bran muffins it would
have been way funnier
i at least would have gotten you would
have gotten a joke immediately and i
think there would have been a whole lot
more hilarity so i just want to say
no it's a correction um it is important
to get these things right we take them
seriously and i speak for myself i will
do
better all right thank god yes
right well if that's all it took
uh well it was not an easy week for me
oh you know yeah no i i didn't
after realizing almost immediately that
i had said
something uh sub-optimal as far as
punchline goes and then having to live
with it through this mo i feel better
now but sure you do
um so right okay i think we all do
i can imagine that yes yes okay so
um i think we should we're going to do
these two ads
so this is obviously very new to us um
and then we will launch and into our
how we feel about ads and we'll talk
about how we feel about ads and then we
will
um do our pro bono ad work right for
eight products that uh you won't see
coming
right um top of the top of the um
top of the list of uh ads zach do you
want to uh
here we go um that little bracket
if you're watching on youtube shows you
that we are now in advertising space
that's right
okay so let's talk vpns vpns yes what is
vpn vpn is a virtual private network and
it is something you definitely need why
do you need it
you need it because we're living in an
era in which we have tremendous security
problems and in which there's all kinds
of forces trying to limit what content
you can view where
that you might want to sidestep so a
virtual private network allows you to do
both these things
it allows you to surf anonymously
even from the perspective of your isp
who frankly in a private window on your
browser can still see where you're going
and in fact in the us your isp is
legally allowed to sell
uh what it sees of your searches to
advertisers
or to to rather to advertisers
potentially but to anyone at once
yes and so you want to shield your
activity from your isp no matter what
it's good practice whether or not you're
surfing anything that they would give a
damn about
or not you just simply should shield
yourself and so
we are uh endorsing expressvpn
so you need a vpn and then the question
is well there are many of them available
to you which one
should you want and i must say i've been
on this vpn thing for a long time
and things have gotten a great deal
better at first it bogged your
connection down
so much that it was a huge trade-off but
now
and you were just constantly aware that
you were interfacing
the internet through via a vpn there was
it was
it was anything but invisible to you the
user right
now at least with expressvp with
expressvpn is quite different the
interface
is thoroughly professional has lots of
choices
they can uh present your connection
from something like 160 different
locations in 94
different countries which is quite a
spectacular diversity
it can be used if you were traveling to
china for example you can use it to
evade the chinese controls on
what you can observe on the internet and
and because it's
um it is not just useful for avoiding
um say people fishing for your
information while you're out in the
world
it's really valuable at home as well
because your isp
is just your internet service provider
is just as able uh
to find and just as willing to find and
source
and sell your information when you're at
home is when you're out in the world
absolutely it's it's a valuable product
to be using at home as well so you can
use it at home
it works on virtually any device you can
think of it certainly works on android
phones
ios phones and tablets uh it works on
most smart tvs which is uh really cool
it'll work on computer whether it's
windows or
mac or linux doesn't matter it can work
on any of these things and it's
incredibly seamless and
the delay if there is any is barely
detectable which is really the most
important thing with one of these you
don't want it to bog down
uh your streaming for example so and
it's also super easy to set up
incredibly easy to set up and it's very
seamless it just sort of lives in it
well at least on mac
it lives in a bar at the top of the
screen you can turn it on and off it
will you can switch what country
you appear to be in so all these things
are important
here's one example of something you
might want to do
i'm not saying you want to do this but
the bbc limits which you can see with
bbc
one player right they put out content
that you can't view from elsewhere in
the world
but if from the perspective of the net
you appear to be in britain you can
watch things now i'm not saying you
should do this because of course
you have to be aware that britain is
part of the five
eyes network and so nothing stops them
from abducting you and
waterboarding you into black site for
having watched the bbc without
permission
but were you willing to take that risk
this mechanism would allow you to do it
wow so um we are
um encouraging you to protect your
online activity today with this vpn
which has been rated number one by both
cnet and wired
so you can visit our link which will
allow you some discounts at
expressvpn.com
darkhorse to receive an extra three
months free on a year's
subscription that's express e-x-p-r
dot com slash darkhorse uh
where you can learn more about
expressvpn and also get that three
months off
offer all right perfect
now something is supposed to happen on
the screen there no no no
not because now now we're going to do
our other other ad
all right um okay so our other ad is for
a product i didn't bring into the room
oh no it's not here it's in the other
room um
so we don't we didn't need to have so
you are going to have to use your
imaginations here now those of you who
are used to listening to us on audio
only are used to imagining up the
visuals
but in this case imagine that we had a
small
bottle well i mean to be fair we didn't
show expressvpn either did we
well that depends rather on whether or
not they're already using it to watch us
where it exists as sort of an invisible
filter okay
um so since we are just uh
clearly quite new to all of this
um and i cannot find my notes for this
the lack of professionalism lends to the
sense of authenticity
it does it does okay um so we are also
uh
encouraging uh the use of a product
called omax cryofreeze
uh and it is basically a stick that you
roll on
uh that helps with pain but before we
talk about it and our experience with it
in particular
we wanted to say a few words about pain
itself pain is useful pain
is an indicator that something has gone
wrong that you've stretched something
too
far that you've ripped something that
something is out of whack something is a
mist
a miss um sometimes pain becomes chronic
at which point that pain signal is far
less useful right
uh and in some cases also even if the
pain is acute
uh if the pain is so bad that you really
can't think straight with it so long as
you take it easy and don't
try to push through now that you don't
experience pain as the result of using a
product
uh what you wouldn't have been able to
do otherwise pain relief can be a very
useful way
you know one of these modern tools that
we had far less access to
uh in in anything but modern times so i
would just
add to that that uh pain is an
adaptation
that it's a signal that you're either
vulnerable or damaged and need to be
extra wary
to protect yourself and
modifying pain by anesthetizing which is
an
ancient tradition is effectively human
beings doing what human beings do we
hack our own systems
for improved effectiveness so you
shouldn't neutralize
every old pain that you have some of
that some of it is important in order to
guide your protection of something
potentially damaged so it can heal but
when
you've got pain that you already know
you've got an issue and
uh you're just sick of dealing with the
pain there is something to do
that's right so uh you wanted to talk a
little bit about our experience with
omax cryofreeze so uh people
send us stuff that they want us to
advertise and we got this
product to test out and see and i must
admit i was a bit skeptical
of it um we went skiing and
i had a kind of a stiff neck after
i do a fair amount of backward skiing
which involves a whole lot of
craning your neck around in order not to
run into things
and and i've never seen you run into
anything
yeah i have run into precious few things
forward or backward but nonetheless my
neck hurt from this thing and i thought
well
what's it gonna hurt so the the uh omex
cryofreeze has cbd in it
and uh so i rubbed it on my neck
and i was um immediately impressed that
it gives you kind of a
cool feeling and it's got mental smells
nice
so uh sort of uh immediately caused your
attention to it but i wasn't really
expecting very much
and then lo and behold the pain went
away and
twice more so i thought that could be
anecdote it could be pain
goes away of its own accord and two more
times i had
pain and i thought okay i'll try it out
um and so
you know there's a lot to be said about
what it is that pain and
one's subjective perception of it is but
i can
say three for three in the case of this
particular product it seemed to go away
i also had a good experience with it and
a friend of ours again this is this is
all anecdote but a friend of ours who
suffers from chronic pain
uh from a number of uh debilitating
injuries in the past
um has had terrific success um
alleviating some of that chronic pain
and i will say finally i was a little
concerned because i have tried cbd
for pain before i've tried uh
cbdt and it triggers
my allergy to marijuana um it causes my
lungs to
fill with goo and so i wondered whether
or not this would too and it definitely
did not
so um and all i can say is that every
experience with it was positive
it did seem to have a good effect and it
didn't trigger the one thing that i
feared might be negative yeah so um omax
health
which is the company that creates uh
omax cryofreeze
is offering um our listeners 20 off a
full bottle of cryofreeze cbd
pain relief roll-on which is the product
that we have used successfully
and this discount is also applying to
any product on their site actually 20
off the entire site go to omaxhealth.com
and enter the code once again
darkhorse so that's omaxhealth.com
the code darkhorse to get 20 off both
cryofreeze which we recommend and any of
their products
sitewide awesome and let us know what
you think yeah
all right we are out of paid advertising
we are out of paid advertising space but
this entire episode we are going to
spend
talking about advertising and then doing
um like i said
eight eight pro bono ads um at the end
which i think we're gonna have some fun
with
all right all right um okay you want to
start us out
yes riffing on advertising so let us
just say we have resisted
participating in advertising for quite
some time we've been approached
numerous times about the possibility and
we have felt and i will speak for myself
i still
feel that advertising is
part of the problem maybe a substantial
part of the problem in fact i would even
say
uh it is something like the root of all
evil that there is something
about human beings in modern times where
from the moment we wake up in the
morning to we go to bed at night we are
constantly being
bombarded by advertisements and while
obviously there is something about
advertisements that could be
informative in general if you watch
advertisements and you say well what
percentage of what's actually going on
here is telling me something i don't
know and what percentage is manipulating
me into feeling some way that may have
nothing to do with the product
or may in fact be paradoxical right
it happens that i may feel some way
about a shampoo based on the fact that
they've
shown an attractive model who is
ostensibly using the shampoo and having
the right effect
on the crowd that the person walks into
i don't know what it is but the point is
at some level
the rational response to advertising
when it is not informative should
probably be to punish the advertiser
right because in some sense if you take
two bottles of shampoo
like let's say you were at the you know
at the market
you looked at two bottles of shampoo and
um
they appeared to be equivalent but one
of them
you had seen an advertisement for and
the other one uh you had not
um at the same price well you would say
well what fraction of the budget for
this shampoo went into advertising
rather than
higher quality ingredients or research
or whatever else might improve the
product well there was in fact a line of
products for a while i haven't seen it
in stores for a while or maybe it's just
not in the stores that i go to
called ad free right that specifically
was
effectively created on the basis that
what you see is what you get
and there's obviously always hidden
costs in the form of r d and packaging
and
you don't know what salary is um but
there's no
you're not paying for them to have
communicated to other people who aren't
you about how great their product is
yes um now the funny thing is because we
are
the monkeys that we are um the
idea of an entire ad-free zone of the
market
does not take off like wildfire because
the fact is we are manipulable and very
frequently we're most manipulated and we
don't even think we're the target
of an advertisement so oh go ahead well
um
you know this might be the right moment
to talk about how advertising is hardly
new to humans
right um that we you know there are many
kinds of ways
that organisms advertise to one another
and we should talk a little bit about
some of those in fact we probably should
have pulled up some pictures but um
i actually think it might be worth just
talking briefly about a framing
a new kind of framing that i believe i
believe you proposed
so whereas darwin first said okay we got
natural selection
and we've got sexual selection uh we're
a natural you know
very broad brush natural selection is
about um
survival and sexual selection is about
reproduction you have proposed
perception mediated selection
um which is that selection um which
can which is about communication between
two entities individuals of some sort
doesn't have to be the same species
in which the perception of the
individual receiving the communicated
signal
is is decide decides what happens next
and the perception may not actually be
reflective of reality
but if the perception is such a thing
then that's going to change behavior and
that's what needs to happen
right so um i didn't know that we were
headed here but yeah
um the uh the point the reason to
declare a different category than the
original darwinian one
is that actually there's a lot of sexual
selection that isn't perception mediated
and behaves much more like natural
selection
yes and then there's a lot of stuff over
in natural selection space that
is perception mediated where you get the
same kinds of stuff you see in sexual
selection and so
really my point is so advertising is all
in perception mediated selection space
right because it is inherently
perception mediated that is to say
whether
you have succeeded or failed is based on
the perception of some other individual
right are you
hiding from them are you augmenting some
characteristic
whether or not it works is dependent on
their perception but the point is
when perception is the mechanism through
which selection is acting
deception is a huge fraction of the game
right so sexual selection looks weird
because so much of it is perception
mediated and therefore deception is all
over the place
well um so deception isn't inherent to
perception immediate selection however
perception opens the door to deception
perception opens the door to deception
right so
um you obviously can have um honest
indicators of quality
um with things like the you know the
song of a bird or the plumage of a bird
uh over in you know traditional sexual
selection space or
honest indicators of say toxicity with
regard to say the clades of frogs that i
have worked on the dark poison frogs in
the neotropics or the mantelas in
madagascar
which are honestly indicating with their
bright coloration
that they also have these toxins on
board these lipophilic alkaloids
and however you also end up with mimics
of the honestly advertising species
that may basically be able to signal
toxicity say without actually bringing
along the cost of having to build the
toxins
so my point would be that the reason
that sexual
selection space looks weird is this
arms race right so females in general
try to force males into displays that
can't be
fixed right right and so uh in some
sense the reason that
so many male displays are so expensive
is that there's no way to build them out
of some material that's
close to free and get away with it
because they wouldn't function so
in any case we can talk more about that
another time but let's just say that in
our
uh cautious embrace of the advertising
modality we are aiming not to manipulate
but to engage in advertising that
informs you about something that you
probably do want to know and at least
think about whether or not the
the object in question is something uh
that you'd be better off
um with and uh certainly deception has
no place
so that this is a small fraction of the
available landscape of things that might
be
advertised that is actually available to
us
yes and indeed um we were we were
approached about a number of products
that we rejected
um and in some cases i think the
products are good products given what
they do
um but we disagree with the premise of
their of
of them being out there in the world in
the way they are or what their claims
are or something and we're not
we're not here to dismiss those products
publicly but just to say that what we
will
end up vouching for here are things that
we actually do
um are are doing without qualms
right and so in some sense the other way
i think of viewing this
is that the reason that i uh
joked about advertising being the root
of all evil
is that it becomes the driving force any
place that
it is the mechanism through which things
are
paid for um so you as the viewer become
the product
you know you are delivered to
advertisers and you get something
ostensibly for free but really it's not
free because
the advertisers wouldn't be paying for
it if they didn't get access to your
mind in a way that they could
affect it you wanted to say something uh
well at some point here i have
a bit to talk about specifically with
regard to people becoming the products
when they
are unwittingly so when they don't know
all right well we'll come back
um so i'll just say um
we in doing this we will have to not do
this
to the extent that there's anything
pulling us in the direction of making
you and the audience
into the product um so
in order for you not to be the product
we have to be
effectively doing double duty which is
to say uh telling you things that we
think are your
in your interest to to know about all
right do you want to uh
yeah um so um
we talked about how advertising is
ancient and
it opens the door to deception without
being inherently deceptive it could just
be
a communication of state of quality
um but uh it certainly you know that
ancient and
sometimes honorable history has
experienced
um quite an acceleration of the
dishonesty
in modern times so i want to just tell
a brief story and then read a tiny bit
from an article written by gloria
steinem in 1990
actually in college i was proud to be a
founding subscriber to the ad-free
version of ms
magazine ms magazine was formed in the
early 70s founded in part by gloria
steinem
as a kind of a feminist magazine that
was about things that would pertain to
things that would be of interest to
women that was not however
a women's magazine women's magazines
tending
to pander to stereotypes
like um you either belong in the kitchen
and there and you know
only with your children and therefore
we're going to
talk about things like cooking and child
care only
or um to other kinds of stereotypes all
you want to do is get a man and so we
are going to
pander to and um i have never felt that
way
you haven't but you yes um
you walked out walked back in and said
that um
pander to uh that part of of
womanhood and so lots of articles on
beauty
and hotness and sexiness and fashion and
and makeup and all
and miz was was not about that so um
what had happened though over the course
of
two-ish decades was that it had a very
very hard time attracting advertisers
who did not dictate content
and so um indeed i actually i did a i
did a big research project on this in
college a couple years
um after this essay that steinem wrote
um
came out researching exactly how
advertisers drive editorial content
specifically
at magazines um directed at teen girls
since i had at that point been a teen
girl recently and had been an occasional
reader of the magazine 17 and was you
know even then
as like a 13 year old because that's
really the target audience of 17.
um you know just appalled and pretty
disgusted
and you know i spent less time with that
magazine than
a lot of people of my generation but i
still i i spent some time with it and i
was still affected
and um i didn't know then but was not
surprised to find out later
how much power the advertisers actually
had on driving the actual so-called
content the editorial content of the
magazine so here's just a couple of
examples
um from and these examples happen to be
from the
steinem article but there are plenty
more out there
during and this is not for girl this is
not for teen girls magazines but
actually at
miz magazine um dao's cleaning products
um were needed to be adjacent to
children or fashion editorial
maiden form which is a maker of bras and
other apparel required that quote no
negative content
be adjacent to the ads including
anything quote relating to
illness disillusionment or large size
fashion
okay de beers diamond company prohibited
magazines from placing its ads next to
quote
hard news or anti-love or romance themed
editorial
okay so this is totally invisible
to most readers of magazines right and
it turns out that for historical reasons
that
i won't go into here women's magazines
and then girls magazines
really were targeted by advertisers more
so
than any of the other magazines because
they were understood to be basically
catalogs for women rather than places
where women could learn
about how to be in the world so um
so one more thing from you know what
what we know
simply from ms magazine which um should
have been more immune to this than
anything else
here's an anecdote that she that that
that steinem reports after years of
trying to get
advertisers even to play ball with her
so she
not only were advertisers coming in the
door and demanding what's called
complementary content content that
actually
put their products into it or said nice
things about their products in the
so-called editorial content
or at least didn't put things they
disagreed with on the same pages or
sometimes on the same issue
but she couldn't even get some
advertisers to come in the door and
here's one story
out of hutzpah and desperation i arrange
a lunch with leonard lotter president of
estee lauder
with the exception of clinique which is
the brainchild of carol phillips
none of lotter's hundreds of products
has been advertised in miz
a year's schedule of ads for just three
or four of them could save us
indeed as the sign of a family-owned
company whose ad practices are followed
by the beauty industry
he is one of the few men who could
liberate many pages in all women's
magazines just by changing his mind
about complementary copy
again complimentary copy is this this
euphemism for
you have to you have to change the
actual content of your magazine if we
are going to put ads in your magazine
over a lunch that cuts costs more than
we can pay for some articles
i steinem explain the need for his
leadership
i also lay out the record of miz more
literary and journalistic prizes won
more new issues introduced into the
mainstream new writers discovered an
impact on society than any other
magazine
more articles that became books stories
that became movies ideas that became
television series
and newly advertised products that
became profitable and most important for
him
a place for his ads to reach women who
aren't reachable through any other
women's magazine
indeed if there is one constant
characteristic of the ever-changing miz
readership
it is their impact as leaders whether
it's waiting until later to have first
babies or pioneering paba as sun
protection and cosmetics
whatever they are doing today a third to
a half of american women will be doing
three to five years
from now it's never failed but he says
ms readers are not our women they're not
interested in things like fragrance and
blush
if they were mis would write articles
about them
on the contrary i explained surveys show
they are more likely to buy such things
than the readers of say cosmopolitan or
vogue
they're good customers because they're
out in the world enough to need several
sets of everything home work purse
travel gym and so on
they just don't need to write articles
about these things no they just don't
need to read articles about these things
would he ask a men's magazine to publish
monthly columns on how to shave before
he advertised aram's products his line
for men
he concedes that beauty features are
often concounted more for advertisers
than readers
but ms isn't appropriate for his ads
anyway he explains
why because estee lauder he says is
selling a kept woman
mentality i can't quite believe this
sixty percent of the users of his
products are salaried and generally
resemble ms readers
besides his company has the appeal of
having been started by a creative and
hardworking woman his mother estee
lauder
that doesn't matter he says he knows his
customers
and they would like to be kept women
that's why he will never advertise and
miz
right so um that's some of what's going
on behind the scenes with advertisers
well can i uh can i riff from there for
a
second
okay so this raises really the next
issue that i was hoping to talk about
which is
i have alleged and i'm trying to
remember where maybe it doesn't matter
maybe it was even here on darkhorse
that part of what is going on with the
derangement
of the west and i really think you know
it's a psychosis of certs that we are
watching where the loss of the ability
um to track arguments and to extrapolate
reasonably and all of that
is actually being driven by the fact
that so much of the landscape through
which we are interacting is
advertising driven and my point is
that that probably means that we are
getting
content that looks very different than
we would otherwise be getting
not because human beings don't want the
higher quality nuanced content but
because
advertisers do not want us in general
in our conscious mind they want us in
our subconscious mind where we
can't necessarily track that we're being
manipulated
and persuaded of things that may not be
factual
right so the idea is factual content
that caused you to have to think might
be very desirable from the point of view
of the consumer of the channel
but it would not be desirable from the
point of view of an advertiser that
really wants you in something you know
just above a sleep level of
of awareness and so uh
in our case i think the answer is
we don't want any ad for which the
advertiser isn't looking to have you in
your conscious mind
evaluating these claims and whether or
not it adds up to you at a conscious
level that's the desire
is only that fraction of advertising
that is not looking to catch you off
guard
that's really good including when the
point of the product is actually both of
the ones that we advertised here today
is to background some complexity so that
you can get on with your life
right um oh that's good i hadn't even
realized that connection between them
yeah
so you do not want to be conscious of
everything
going on in your life at all times that
gets um
you know deeply painful and becomes
unproductive very quickly
but you want to be able to call to
consciousness anything that you are
being exposed to any decisions you are
making
before deciding actually i want to set
and forget i do want to have brand
loyalty over in this space because i
just don't care about
laundry detergent that much or whatever
it is right but you need at any moment
to be able to say wait actually it's
time to reassess
and i i think um we will certainly never
we will never advertise anything with
our words
where we are trying to subvert that
process and
any you know we will because we
scrutinize all of these things and we
have been approached by
many different potential advertisers we
think about them very consciously so
yep when we bring them to you it's
because they passed that process
so um i guess maybe we want before we
embark on our eight pro bono ads
um to talk a little i mean i think
you've already done it but um given how
we
clearly feel about advertising and what
we what kinds of harms we know it does
in the world
why would we want anything to do with it
we're doing we're doing
well right now thank you to the many
supportive and
and generous viewers and listeners and
people on our patreon
um we are at the moment doing well but
it is to some degree at the uh
um at the discretion discretion of
youtube patreon and google and and
youtube and google being the same thing
um and so diversifying as much as
possible where it is that we are
um how it is that we are generating our
our money
so that we can continue to speak
absolute truth
without being um without being dependent
on the pleasure of someone you know at
any point
that someone whom we are advertising
says actually it's not working for me
they paul that's fine
and at any point that we someone
approaches us and says we want you to
advertise for them and we say not for us
we just don't go there so i would also
point out
and this is delicate because it is very
difficult
to prove in any way that would be clear
but
we get access to the back channel
information
for the dark horse youtube channel for
example
and it has ceased adding up the podcast
appears to be more popular than ever
which you would expect news of it would
spread
and people seem to very much like it
on the other hand we see a trend
in viewership coming from google
that clearly indicates that in spite of
the fact that it's popular with those
who see it that they're showing it to
fewer people
and so what does this pretend would they
boot us
you know at the point that they thought
it wouldn't cause a stir i don't know
but let us just say it is a
vulnerable position and from the point
of view you know of our
long-term ability to speak the truth
irrespective of
what comes at us it is it is important
that we carefully take this step
indeed um did you want to say anything
about advertising to children or should
we save that
um yeah it's probably worth as long as
we're spending the topic
the time here i would just say that you
know as a measure of how
dangerous advertising has become i have
for
at least 15 years been making the claim
that i believe there is no defense
of advertising to children
that it is impossible to come up with a
rationale whereby it is acceptable for
example
to have the a company that produces food
advertising to children in a way that
might change what it is they desire to
eat or how much they desire to eat
and that clearly we have an epidemic of
ill health based
in inability to regulate desire for
food both type and amount amongst
children for which there is no
known cause other than the fact that we
have lots of corporations
uh pushing various things in the
direction of children so anyway i keep
asking
can anybody come up with a defense of
the right of a company to advertise to a
child who is presumably without the
defenses that an adult might have and
even
adults aren't all that well defended
right
and so i guess what i would say in
closing is
that the degree of harm
that comes from disregulating children's
interaction with something like food and
the same could be said of a lot of other
things you know what what it is they
desire and are therefore
persuaded to pursue that advertising to
children
effectively maims people right it does
things that are as harmful to them
as i don't know child molesting
something like that and to the extent
that the society allows this to continue
and doesn't do anything even though it
is at least very difficult and maybe
impossible to come up with a
justification
that makes any sense is a measure of how
much we have
fallen into the trap of imagining that
advertising is just like a feature of
the landscape
and not something that we uh grant
access
very good all right um should we should
we do our pro bono
okay um we're gonna alternate right
wow this is not going well so far it's
not going well
for those of you just listening i just
dropped several things off screen
for most of these products we both have
an in and we have a relationship with
the product
your relationship with this product is i
think entirely through my relationship
with the product so
um if you are an avid reader of physical
books
and you don't know about book darts you
should if you
read books but it's all online or you
don't really care for books that much
and you never find yourself going to
your bookshelf and
opening books that you've read before
you don't want this product
but if you do have you know upon moving
into a home
insist that one of the first things that
needs to happen is that we need to
install
lines and lines of bookshelves as we did
here um
then this this is an amazing and amazing
thing so book darts are little tiny
markers
um that um made of metal
that are better than inking up your book
better than bookmarks better than
post-it flags
they stick but they aren't permanent
they don't deform the book no matter
how many are in there um so i have this
pile which
because zach has zoomed out on me you
can't see but this pile of books i just
pulled five books
off of our shelves that i know that i
had read or reread recently enough
to have book darted and so this one
which we will probably spend a whole
episode talking about at some point
anatomy of an epidemic i don't know if
you can see just how many book darts are
inside that by the little by the little
glimmers
but the book is not deformed by it and
any time that i pick up a book that i've
read i open it to anyone of book darts
and i see
not just something of value from the
book but something about my state of
mind when i was reading it what caught
my eye
and it's sort of it's a it's a it's a
kind of
memory hack i find and a way
to reinsert myself into into long pieces
of text either fiction or non-fiction
that i've enjoyed before
but might be unlikely to pick up and
read from scratch again
so um i have several of these tins
around the house
uh brett can attest to that and i think
you're now so accustomed to the telltale
sound
of the tin being opened that sometime if
i'm reading it in bed at night
you'll hear that and find something to
book dart honey
right um so i just i literally pulled
five books that i
respect off the shelf and open them to
one of the book darted places i'm just
gonna read you
a sentence or two from each of these
book dart places um which also will
reveal
five books that i think are terrific um
i don't actually have it
just uh i did not decide an order in
advance
so we'll start with anatomy of ep of an
epidemic by robert whittaker
extraordinary and terrifying book
just one line in this he says
with regard to a presenter at an apa
audience
i conclude that patients with
schizophrenia not on antipsychotic
medication for a long period of time
have significantly better global
functioning than those
on antipsychotics that alone
is worth the price of admission to this
book when you see that there
there are data to support the idea that
antipsychotics are likely doing more
harm than good
so that's one we have
actually i'll do the fiction last we
have um margaret mead
sex and temperament and three primitive
societies um so
actually introduction by helen fisher
who we know
so this is originally written in 1935
and
just from the introduction one of the
things i bookmarked
i book darted is um
uh two of these tribes have no idea that
men and women are different in
temperament
they allow them different economic and
religious roles different skills
different vulnerabilities to evil magic
and supernatural influences
the arapech believed that painting in
color is appropriate only to men
and the mandugamore consider fishing an
essentially feminine feminine task
but any idea that temperamental traits
of the order of dominance bravery
aggressiveness objectivity malleability
are inalienably associated with one sex
as opposed to the other is entirely
lacking this may seem strange to a
civilization which is in its
which in its sociology it's medicine
it's slang it's poetry and its obscenity
accepts the socially defined differences
between the sexes as having an innate
basis
she goes on so fascinating little bit of
cultural anthropology there from
margaret mead from the early part of the
20th century
we have um alice drager's excellent book
galileo's middle finger heretics
activists in the search for justice and
science
in which among many other uh revelations
and this is published
boy this is probably going to be 2016
2015. you gave this to me
probably 2017. um
you brett um
that didn't so this is from chapter five
the rot from within
that didn't mean that these scientists
or i or anyone else existed without bias
it didn't mean their work wasn't shaped
and sometimes tainted by politics
ideologies and loyalties
but it didn't mean they tried to adhere
to an intellectual agenda that wasn't
first and only political
if they believed that good science
couldn't be done just by just ouija
boarding your answers
good scholarship had to put the search
for truth first on the quest for social
justice second
that's drager a while ago a while ago a
while ago
i got you that before we met her am i
right yes yes
yes um before evergreen blew up yeah
before
back in the before time another kind of
before times yep
um this excellent novel mating by norman
rush which was actually
i i see from the inscription given to me
as a gift by elizabeth wright
when we were all on barrow colorado
island together when she was writing a
book that
um largely starred you
um tape yours morning bath tate pier's
morning bath yeah
um so she gave me this book thinking i
would enjoy it and it's really
extraordinary
and here's a line here's a slight
paragraph from it
with where she's the author here is
speaking about his protagonist
one thing one thing wrong with america
according to danoon is that the society
is converging to suppress
unsupervised mass play largely through
the mechanisms of tv and adult-run
sports like little league
his theory was that if you leave young
males alone they will go in place
situations from fascism
to feudalism to democracy so now there
is a diffuse and a thwarted attraction
to
fascism excuse me um that is getting
played out at the adult level
he was fecund with theories
[Laughter]
and one more just again to point out how
how rich
the leaving behind a trail of book darts
can be in terms of finding
finding evidence of great thinking in
the books on yourself
this is um from a novel another
excellent novel called the overstory
by powers that just came out a year or
two ago i think
um and
this about one of the protagonists again
the clarity of recent weeks the sudden
waking from sleepwalk his certainty that
the world has been stolen in the
atmosphere trash for the shortest of
short-term gains
the sense that he must do all he can to
fight for the living world's most
renderous creatures
all these abandon adam and he's left in
the insanity of denying the bedrock of
human existence
property and mastery nothing else counts
earth will be monetized until all trees
grow in straight lines
three people own all seven continents
and every large organism is bred to be
slaughtered
you did all that with book darts huh
yeah i i did all that with book cards
yeah so that's that's my pitch for book
darts yeah you know it's actually it's
kind of marvelous because the fact that
they um
do not physically alter the book in a
permanent way
but do physically live in the book in a
way that it's easier to find than if
you've written something i've never been
a fan of this
you know if you don't write in your
books you're not you're a faker kind of
a
mentality for one thing i would never
write in a book because
a i wouldn't be able to read it right so
what good would it do
and b it just feels like dif you know
defacing something and maybe if one had
marvelous penmanship it would be
different but yeah and i
so one thing i do when i when i'm just
taking a book out into the world and if
i don't have a bag with me and so don't
also have a tin of book darts is
i line the last pages page of the book
with just a line of book dart so that if
i do come upon something that i want to
remember for later
i can pull it off the back page and put
it where it goes
totally and if you do find yourself out
and you don't have them you can go into
any 711 and you can ask
the person behind the counter and get a
quizzical look for free for free for
free physical looks for free at almost
at any 7-eleven near you actually yes
any so
at your local stuff or you can drive
across the state to a different 7-eleven
if you want a variety sure
sure um okay that's that's ad number one
of
eight ad number one you were gonna do
this one yes which you didn't want me to
say by name no
okay so i wanted to talk to you all
about the question
of security do you ever look at your
home
and worry that somebody is going to
sneak into your backyard
break in and take your stuff and then
you think well
what would the best solution to this be
right
there's obvious dangers to having a
firearm what you really need
are dinosaurs right a good dinosaur will
give a burglar
a scare like they wouldn't believe oh
man
what are you gonna do how are you gonna
get them are you gonna go online and buy
some dinosaurs you could
but they might fly off so
the best thing to do
this is awesome it's a little goofy all
right
the best thing to do is to attract wild
dinosaurs
to your backyard
actually zach do you want to show uh i
sent you a couple of dinosaur pictures
yeah um yeah here's one i took that
picture just
yesterday of a little that's a big
bird oh it's a little one it's a little
in and here
is how i attracted it to our backyard in
order to scare off
would-be burglars and if i may you
you bought so for people just listening
you've got a hummingbird at some kind of
a
glass and metal contraption which you
bought at the
thing that you're advertising here which
is extent dinosaur stores
yeah at the extent dinosaur store
yeah which goes by various names
depending on where you are by the way
uh i got you a little something uh i
know what you're thinking you're
thinking
it's not your birthday which it isn't
but um this is from the extent dinosaur
story it is from the extent should i
open it up you should open it right wow
okay the extent dinosaur store
and brett have delivered unto me
um this is actually you know remarkably
well wrapped for it dude
i was actually i was going to say that
as i
grow except it's got a prime box older
and more
manly i get worse and worse at wrapping
presents
okay okay so i did not see this coming
guys the extent dinosaur
oh look at this okay the extent dinosaur
store
does not sell extent dinosaurs but it
sells ways to
attract them there you go and ways to
break in after you've attracted them
except i can't open it oh i don't even
know how this guy lifts up on the side
there
oh on the side yeah and there's a little
critter even that's not an extent
dinosaur but something
no that's an arthropod oh it looks like
um cool so what kind of extent dinosaur
is this
nest box um likely to attract do you
know you know it's funny when you're
covered in a
harvard nesting material um
but uh thank you yeah you're welcome um
i feel safer already as well you should
can we arm the birds though because that
it feels to me would solve a couple
problems
um yes i there may be regulations on
this that we would want to
check on before engaging in any
any army of birds yeah i also got you uh
some of that uh insect and hot pepper
suet you like
wow yum i think i'm i think i won't eat
that on air but
uh but this is this is fabulous even if
you're not an extent dinosaur yourself
actually no i think really you have to
be an extent dinosaur which is to say
an avian dinosaur a bird yes
so anyway the the advertisement here is
for your
local bird supply shop to attract these
animals to your
your uh your yard and i will say
but there's something um important here
which is that the hot pepper
is here not because birds love hot
pepper but because mammals don't yeah
and birds can't birds can't detect it
yes in fact the capsaicin
here's the beautiful thing about that
story is it turns out that the capsaicin
was loaded into chili peppers because
chili peppers are distributed by
birds and it is loaded in to trick
mammals into thinking that they are
doing
damage to themselves when they eat the
chili peppers so the chili peppers will
be left over
for birds to eat and therefore
distribute the seeds which they do much
better
than mammals dim so the thing is
i always think it is a good idea to
attract
extant dinosaurs whether or not they're
keeping you safer but i never think it
at the right time of year and this time
it's the right time of year at least
here in the northern hemisphere it's
spring so the
animals are nesting and putting up bird
boxes is a good idea
and so anyway that's why this birthday
present is a little early
that's awesome thank you yeah more bugs
more birds
more beautiful
yeah maybe need a little help on the ad
copy but that's okay that's okay
insect and hot pepper suet excellent
insect and hot peppers to it
all right um are we done with the extent
dinosaur stores ad
i believe so okay so pro bono ad 2
extent dinosaur stores
um pro bono ad three um
is for did you find a picture of me in
the jungle
i sure did okay zach you want that now
um
no hold on a second zach yeah no we
could put it up
so the next time you find yourself in
the jungle do yourself a favor and wear
eggle boots now is this in fact from
our time in the amazon list okay so my
most recent trip i'm in fact wearing
eagle boots here in the amazon the
jungle
for those who don't know is more
accurately called you could take it off
whenever
um lowland tropical rainforest okay
uh jungles can be found in honduras and
costa rica
in brazil and ecuador and madagascar and
indonesia
um and uh india and papua new guinea
lots of places
uh among many uh among many other places
but let's parse
the term for a moment why you know why
boots
in jungles why this particular type of
boots and jungles well
a jungle being a lowland tropical
rainforest uh
is lowland tropical in a rainforest
lowland refers to elevation
um so it's close to sea level tropical
refers to it being within 23 and a half
degrees of the tropic of the equator
that's within the tropic lines
and both proximity to the equator and
elevation um
are correlated with a high biodiversity
and low and tropical ecosystems are
going to be high biodiversity lots of
critters
that are interested in in getting at you
or
or in other ways kind of maybe just
impeding your progress
rainforest just refers to the type of
precipitation that falls as opposed to
cloud forest and cloud forest the
precipitation tends to hang as water
droplets and clouds um it does of course
rain but the experience
of being in a cloud forest is very much
a being in a cloud and the experience of
being in a rainforest is very much of
um being frequently quite wet because
you're being rained on
the rain is seasonal but the seasons are
like wet and wetter
uh and um that means mud
okay so you've got this hot wet seething
massive biodiversity
in the jungle which again um lowland
tropical rainforest being the technical
term
and um it's kind of a heaven for some of
us some of us really
are driven to go there and we were lucky
enough to be in the amazon in january of
2020 just before the entire world
locked down but it is as i said
deeply and unendingly muddy and
there's also except in some places like
madagascar
tend to be a fair number of poisonous
snakes so
to protect yourself from both mud and
snakes you wear
as close to knee-high as you can get
rubber boots the rubber boots
mean that you don't get mud into your
shoes as you're slogging through and
occasionally step into deep mud puddles
which happens a lot
and the thick rubber keeps his
protection against a snake bite if you
should manage to step on one because
they tend to be cryptic
and it um it comes at you i've only had
that happen
once that i know of where i actually saw
a uh a fertile on strike at my boot
um and i wasn't wearing eagle boots then
but i was wearing boots that were good
enough it was actually in the amazon it
was in the brazilian amazon
um no actually that was in costa rica
that was in costa rica i stepped on one
in the brazilian amazon as well but it
uh it just eyed me and i got away um
without it striking at me um so when
as you know when we led our study abroad
trip in 2016 and when i led the several
that i led before that
um the one one of the very few actually
hard and fast rules that i had was
jungle boots at all times no matter what
when you're in the forest
no exceptions and a lot of field
stations have a lot of rules about
keeping people safe including you can
never go into the forest alone never
going to the jungle alone
i actually reject that rule completely
once once you are
once you know something about what
you're doing and have demonstrated
proficiency
in how to navigate and um and deal with
things that come up
i actually i'm not sure i've enforced
going solitarily into the jungle but it
was certainly one of the things that i
really strongly encourage because
there's nothing like it being alone in
the jungle with just you
and well your jungle boots and you know
whatever else you're wearing
um but
the boots were non-negotiable because of
the mud because of the snakes
and the fact is that cheap rubber boots
are available
in towns near jungles every place that
we've been
even i think even i think in madagascar
where there's almost nothing available
they tend to be lower than might be
optimal you know if you're dealing with
big terrestrial vipers they can launch
themselves
a little bit higher and you don't you
don't want to risk that
and they tend to be a little thin they
tend to be flimsy most of what they tend
to be is really uncomfortable
yeah and your blisters they give you
blisters you can get them on and off
um easily to you know empty them of
water after you've been
drenched in another downpour but um but
they're not comfortable and if you're
actually
interested in slogging around the jungle
all day as some of us are and i
encourage everyone who has the
opportunity to do so
you want these boots so they're not
cheap
but they're amazing they're eagle boots
eagle a-i-g-l-e
eagle boots right here on the the
podcast
first podcast um these were first
actually introduced to me by a student
of ours
on that um on that study abroad trip
she was she was going on about how great
they were and
they were not cheap and i thought how
good could they possibly be
they wrap up tight they feel so
comfortable they're actually impermeable
to
fangs uh and they're fabulous yes they
are not
cheap except in comparison to not having
them yes
yeah exactly yeah if you're gonna spend
serious time
um they're worth having and they're also
uh great
uh in the garden doing various things
that you wouldn't want to do in shoes
that will
pick up mud and they will pick up mud on
the bottom yes but you don't wear them
inside
no you don't wear them inside but yeah
actually i was going to say too and you
know pacific northwest
winters in particular i wear these when
i'm out walking or when i'm out
um trying once again to div the
landscape which is an endless task but
uh these boots make it better
yeah yes yeah okay all right that's add
number three
um eggle boots mm-hmm
there you are okay uh the fourth one
yes um so there's a kind of a category
that is developing here
i think everything of our pro bono ads
so far these are a few of our favorite
things things that you
our audience should know about in case
you're going to be involved in any of
these activities or
might want to be involved in some
activity you don't yet know about and so
i'm going to advocate for getting
involved
in these bad boys here this is
a trail camera and trail cameras exist
primarily i think for hunters hunters
put these
up in places in order to figure out
where the game is and
when it's around and when it isn't
around but
they are also widely used now by
naturalists to figure out
what the behavior patterns of animals
are
and it's also tremendously fun just to
figure out
whether or not you're studying creatures
to figure out what's available so
i will yeah um at tippatini in the
ecuador and amazon where that picture
that you showed
of me and the eagle boots was taken
there was a long time camera trap study
uh with uh run by a man named diego
moscara who at that point was the field
manager for the station
um and with the with the help of these
so-called camera traps these game
cameras
he found that there were um i think
there was
primatologists already knew that there
were ten species of primates but it was
his camera trap work
um that revealed five different species
of cats of wild cats at tippatini and so
they're
super useful um as a research tool as
well totally
and yeah i must say it is marvelously
fun and addictive to deploy these things
hey you learn a lot you deploy them
somewhere you think is going to be good
and it isn't and you sort of you learn a
lot about the animals just in figuring
out where they're going to be
things you couldn't possibly validate
without the camera because
the animals are really good at avoiding
you in many cases and so
anyway these come in different kinds um
they come
in a regular flash camera version that
takes night photos with the flash i'd
recommend against
that and then there are two versions
that don't spook the animals there's a
low glow that has a light red glow
animals do not see red in general
nocturnal animals don't
and then there's a no glow pure infrared
one and anyway
they record a little sd card whatever
they see and then you come collect the
sd card there's some fancy ones now that
if you have cell service where you
deploy them they will
email you uh images of animals that
happen by
which can be kind of neat um
i have uh i've deployed a couple cameras
in a local wildlife area so the story is
i was down there on my bike
and actually somebody recognized me um
and i was talking to them and as we were
talking looking out over the nature
reserve there was clearly
some sort of large-bodied mammal but we
didn't know what it was
and um anyway i narrowed it down it had
to be one of a number of things it had
to be either
otter or beaver or um
could be nutria link well
i was already interested i knew there
were minks in this nature area and i was
interested to figure out where they were
do they swim much minks yeah minks are
always found
on the shore of water i don't know i
mean i'm sure they can swim but i don't
know that they do swim all that much but
they are
closely associated with water so otter
beaver or nutria were there
three most likely sort of the three most
likely suspects and that so i went down
there and started poking around a little
bit uh that picture of the bald eagle in
flight that i showed last time was me
standing there
trying to get a beat on these mammals
and the bald eagle flew over
um and anyway i did see the animals a
second time but i couldn't figure out
what they were they were too far off
and so i set up multiple uh two animals
yeah
large bodied dark low
so anyway i deployed a game camera and
uh zach do you want to show
what i came up with after about two
weeks of um
um well why don't you show
all of it okay so here's the first thing
that is a beaver can you step through
the images
so that is a beaver emerging from the
water being
filmed with infrared there you can see
its eye shining back at the camera
here's the second beaver coming out of
the water it's going to go
up slope here
[Music]
all right so beaver that's really
exciting beaver is a rodent
and it's one of my favorite rodents such
an interesting creature
they can be very shy here's the second
creature that the camera picked up
now i think this is a muskrat and not a
nutria it could be a nutria though
my sense of it being a little bit better
it's squatter then yeah it's a little
smaller but nutrient
and muskrat so watch this it's going to
take off into the water here
and once it's in the water it's almost
indistinguishable really yeah
all right nice um keep going zach
here's during the day oh look it's a
pair of river otters
so this is a nature area that is on a
tributary of
the willamette river which runs right
through portland
and so these are two river otters that
uh
presumably enter the water here and then
swim right out into the willamette and
hunt fish
and maybe and shake their little otter
fists at the boaters
probably they do uh you can see it's
raining as they're descending into the
water that's what i think we saw
looking out at the uh i'm pretty sure it
was gonna be otters that were glumping
along
when i couldn't identify when you were
talking with the guy yeah for one thing
it was during the day
and the otters here it's not i mean and
the beavers here are
um at least partially nocturnal probably
entirely nocturnal
and now this last one's gonna be a
little bit difficult to make out
but um it's on a crocodile isn't it no
for those of you who are photographers
rule of thirds
in the vertex of thirds in the lower
left-hand part of the
screen you've got a little four-legged
animal
uh with a long tail there that is a mink
so this one camera this is all from one
camera
it's all from one camera over the course
of it looks like less than a week
yeah in the day one in one go this
camera caught all of these things
and it's amazing i mean a this is well i
mean to be to be fair though
you know you've got decades training
honing a naturalist
eye not just as a field biologist but
also as a photographer and so
you put it in the right place right like
you could have put it somewhere where it
wouldn't have caught anything
i did and indeed i've got one uh
deployed right now that
caught absolutely nothing so that's a
thing that happens
and you know uh anyway it's a fun game
if you want a game that
you know is is very real figuring out
how to get the wildlife to show up on
your
game camera is um is a pretty good one
and so i guess uh yeah you want to show
the video this is from our backyard
this is a coyote they unfortunately in
portland
uh hunt house cats quite actively
and this is literally oh probably
40 feet from our back deck beautiful
animal
um so that's actually from last two
years ago yeah
that is from two years ago just a very
high quality video so it does prove that
you can get
really good quality uh video and
pictures off
out of these things if you place them
carefully and uh
um anyway yes so that's uh cool stuff so
yeah you've been getting some
um we've got unfortunately three coyotes
right here
over the last several days uh oh yeah
pictures of we have been
yeah and i will show some pictures at
some point indeed actually last week
people remember i was looking at an
animal out the window that i said was
very dark
i now know from multiple kinds of
evidence that it had to be a coyote and
my sense that it was very dark
was off everything else adds up maddie
went to the spot
and immediately picked it out and
started looking around for something and
now i've camera trapped around the area
the coyotes come right through there and
so that's what i saw out the window
and for those of you who might be
concerned are if you hear yowling now
it's because our cats are pissed because
they're not allowed outside while
there's this many coyotes right here who
are clearly waiting for them
yeah they're waiting for snacks um but
anyway
think about whether i mean you can get
these pretty cheap you know for
a hundred bucks you can you can get one
that does the basics
and then you know you can go up from
there um you got any in particular that
you recommend because you've now got a
few different
types yeah i would say i don't i
wouldn't worry too much about
no glow versus low glow i think low glow
is just fine doesn't spook the animals
at all but don't go flash yeah don't go
with the visible flash
i would say i like the bushnell
cameras get one that has a screen
so you can see what the camera is going
to shoot rather than being surprised
when you pick up your sd card
yeah and it's also really useful if they
have
a a visible led and a setting to
test where the trigger zone is
so basically you can set it to test and
then you can walk out where you expect
an animal to be if you're on a deer
trail or something like that
and you can just make sure that if you
walk there you see the led go off then
you know it triggers
but anyway yeah i like the bushnell ones
are pretty good and i would say
you can go to trailcam pro the
website and they have very good reviews
on things and you can see
you know they have all kinds of stuff
that you can bolt things to trees and
um they all come with a strap for a
reasonably small tree you can uh
just strap them onto the the tree it's
easier to aim them if you have something
with a little bit of a you know tripod
head
versatility like that but anyway it's a
fun game
and i'd be curious what you come up with
if you if you do manage to
to capture something beautiful
beautiful okay our fifth of eight pro
bono ads
is for comcast comcast as many of you
will know is the largest home internet
and cable tv provider in the united
states
uh and it's the second largest
broadcasting
and cable tv company in the world after
att so
at least for our listeners and viewers
in the us and many outside of the us as
well
you're going to be pretty familiar with
it so what can we say that hasn't been
said already
well comcast has the most amazing name
recognition
really that's that's the best i can do
really it's
hard to avoid if you can say one
positive thing about comcast it is that
it is ubiquitous
it's everywhere uh in fact it's really
hard to opt out if you want internet or
cable tv especially if you live in some
places
uh you just you're stuck with with
comcast they have in fact this little
thing
uh approaching what we like to call
monopoly in many places
um that of course makes them less
enthusiastic about customer service
than they might otherwise be why give a
[ __ ] about your customers if you have
them over a barrel
after all also now that comcast actually
owns some content they did you know that
they
have bought nbc universal so that's part
of the comcast family now
and then they're also of course in
charge of content distribution in the
form of isps well there seems to
possibly be an antitrust issue there as
well
um and there's also the little problem
of their position on net neutrality
um their resistance to any but the
narrowest form of it
and some evidence that they have acted
really not in any way on behalf of the
consumers
so all of which leaves customers of
comcast often feeling
underwhelmed at best by their service
but we have a code to help you with
uh with your experience at comcast so
that you might be able to get something
truly special
use code bend over at checkout and
receive a customer service experience
that you're unlikely to ever
forget so uh i will say
um comcast uh may be the actual root of
all evil and it may just
sort of function through advertising or
something but um we had the most
spectacular run of it wasn't even bad
luck it was just
comcast there was no luck involved it
was comcast it was comcast so what we
had was a situation in our in our
previous house where for
years we could not get a stable internet
connection through
comcast and there was no alternative
right and those two things are
undoubtedly connected
um so this went on year after year they
must have come out
eight times a year always claimed to
have solved it it never worked
i replaced every modem and router
multiple times to make sure it wasn't
something on our end it wasn't cheap
simply did not work and then the crazy
thing is
we moved here there was no option for
anything other than comcast so we signed
up for it and we thought maybe it's at
least
just our old zip code or something
the problem followed us here and indeed
people who
remember our early live streams will
remember how
unstable they were well that wasn't just
us that lifted at the point
that centurylink introduced fiber optic
and we finally had the ability
to get rid of comcast and we got rid of
them completely we don't get
our television content through them how
much did you enjoy the phone
conversation that you had with comcast
where you
cut the ties it was so awesome i
totally if you find that you're in an
abusive relationship with
comcast what you need to do is just
walk away you will feel so much better
when comcast walking taller out of your
life right
it's just it's um it's incredible what a
terrible corporation it is and what a
low quality product it delivers at such
a high price
yeah no it's it's all of those things
terrible corporation
awful product high price yeah what could
be better get yourself some book darts
some boots and a trail camera instead
you'll be happy you did
indeed okay next ad you have called
wtaf see
right this is my acronym uh for what the
actual [ __ ]
costco um now mind you i don't hate
costco dope
i don't love shopping there but the fact
is i think there's a lot to recommend
the place
they do seem to source some pretty high
quality
stuff the prices are good we have too
much
choice in general so sacrificing a bit
of choice in order to get a really good
price
they apparently treat their employees
well they treat their employees well so
it's not a
general complaint about costco at all on
the other hand
i have this experience and i can't quite
get over it
so i bought a shaver now the reason i
bought the shaver was that my last
shaver which was actually okay
it was a phillips shaver that had one
defect that was an
absolute deal killer the defect was
that they had the button was a big
lever on the front of the thing and
there was no way to pack it into
any item any luggage there was nothing
you could do to prevent it from turning
on
in the luggage anytime you checked your
bag at the point your bag came
off of the plane into the rotating
carousel whatever it's been so long
since we've flown i don't remember
um your bag would be humming yeah it was
crazy it even happened once in the
overhead compart i think the turbulence
set the thing up so anyway i needed a
new
shaver and so i looked at this one and
it had all sorts of cool stuff some of
which i didn't exactly need but okay
you know i'm not planning to do a lot of
manscaping you know
i mean it's just but wait and did you
see an advertisement for this in one of
the many men's magazines you read
ah no i didn't see it in any of the
men's magazines i don't read
which is all of them yes um but here's
the thing okay so i got it home
and i was uh pretty excited to open it
up
and out popped this the box for the
actual
product it's only this big now
what the actual [ __ ] causes you to
disguise
this in this because this may strike you
as
like that's insane right right for those
listening
that's close to two-thirds of the box
that has nothing in it
yeah it has nothing in it and it's
actually made of stuff
right now i live on this planet my
children live on this planet i don't
want to see it liquidated any faster
than
necessary right and i'm forced to ask
all kinds of questions did they ship it
like this from china
or did they erect this box here it just
doesn't make any sense
and it's not like this is particularly
stealable i don't think that's it
i think it's one of these considerations
like
bigger that's better there's more stuff
in there
or it takes up more real estate on the
thing and catches your attention i don't
know what the hell explains it but
please [ __ ] stop the extra packaging
is killing us and i if i can just extend
this to other places like
apple right okay this gorgeous packaging
that everything comes in the stuff
that's too good to throw away
so you fill your attic with boxes oh
what if i sell the machine
i need to box it you know i mean come on
the fact is we have an environment
right we don't need that and just as we
should penalize advertisers who
advertise at us without informing us
they're manipulating us we've penalized
them
we should penalize entities that sell us
more packaging than is necessary i don't
want the stuff packaged in such a flimsy
way that it's broken when i get it
that's also bad for the planet but for
god's sake can you just make it simple
right simple packaging recyclable
packaging
that's what we want that's right
rant over no it's excellent okay two
more ads
in this uh in this pro bono ad edition
of dark grass and
incidentally we didn't say that we are
going to um
as as we are beginning to advertise
actual things for which we are being
paid
we are going to continue to do these pro
bono ads for things that we
that we find that we feel like and i
should say we didn't do this one thing
but um people are free to send us
products that they want us to advertise
if you send us something really bad we
may do a pro bono ad about the bad
product so be warned
only send us stuff you believe in
excellent
um okay so this next one is um is
a mishmash it's basically um
an advertisement for artisans artisans
of all sorts
artisans and and craftsmen and
um you know we have received some
amazing gifts we you know i
we are both to some degree artisans and
craftspeople ourselves
but we have also received some
remarkable things since we have been
doing darkhorse and before
and i just wanted to highlight a few of
those things
um and encourage everyone if you have
any interest whether or not you think
you have any ability
to to find a craft find something over
an arts or craft space that you can
you can start to do so one
is this this ceramicist matthew kelly so
zack you can show my screen here
um this is his sight he makes beautiful
things he does
um among he has several different kinds
of um
firings and this if i forgot to look it
up this mug that i'm holding is from
his salt kiln that i think he built
truly truly gorgeous work we also have
um we were sent so zach you can take
take that down now
um i i forgot to look into it but um
this beautiful little leather case with
these leather
dark horse coasters totally love the
coasters love the coasters we use them
all the time you probably because of the
way our um
our cameras are aimed at the moment you
can't see that our stuff is sitting on
these coasters
um i thought they were gonna stain they
don't stain they don't stain and
actually um the guy i'm sorry i didn't
look back at um the the guy who sent
them to us said i don't know if they'll
work as coasters i just work in leather
and i thought i'd make these for you
they were
wonderful um this incidentally these
glasses that you sonoma see us drinking
from
are not um a gift to us because of what
we do here these are things we found
at the farmers market in ashland oregon
a couple of years ago
made you know bought from the glass
worker who actually
um made them zach do you want to show
the
oh i didn't the picture that i sent you
of the horse
and i'm gonna quickly look on my phone
to see if i got
um i'm not positive
who the artist is and i'm really sorry
about that but when we find out we'll
put it in the show notes
these people sent us this gorgeous piece
of arts wood burned
and they have their names on the back of
it but we hung it on a wall and it
didn't easily come off the wall
so that's why i'm not using their names
here
we have next item
[Music]
this zachary
giant herbs and tea here in portland
oregon
the guy behind this is an herbalist
and um and also now team maker who
um who has is doing a tremendous amount
with sort of
traditional medicine and tinctures and
stuff and he sent us a box
of um chais and tinctures and we have
enjoyed all of them that we've tried so
far but i just wanted to highlight two
of you that is an herbalist and
tea wizard i can tell you from having
drunk these teas they're really great
they're amazing so here we have a kid
you not
dark horse horse h-o-a-r-s-e chai
on to which he's written this logical
blend will make you want to analyze its
components why does this taste
so good and on the back a unity of
flavors without any hint of evergreen
perfect during a long day of voice work
sit back and grok this chai while
discussing a heterodox opinion or
reminding people where you really stand
this chai is an olfactory wake-up call
so that's awesome
and a little bit disappointingly maybe
maybe my favorite one he sent us like 12
or 14 of these but maybe my favorite
giant of his that i've had so far is
antifa chai it's antifa chai
um and on it he's written there are no
leaders here but its flavor shows up and
burns on the way down
a dash of horseradish to make the eyes
water chipotle and paprika to warm you
up an accent of guarana to keep the mind
alert
a great drink to get you amped before
your soccer match
so these are great i you know i
recommend
all of all of his all of his work and
then
um just one more artisan particular i
mean
all artisans everywhere but our friend
um dave stevens who many have remarked
on the knife um
on in the back corner in the sink um
is a metalsmith and he made he made me
swordsmith he he's a swordsmith and he
made me
this machete so i also in addition to
eagle boots depending on where i am
will also sometimes carry a machete uh
when i'm in the field
usually not you know not it to patini
it's not necessary but i have been in
places where i needed it both for vines
and
for protection um not against snakes but
against
drug runners actually um that's another
story
uh but this is gorgeous this is so
enough
you can see the pattern yeah oh no now
i'm on a different camera
here you go um so i'm sure
dave's watching he's like show it a
different way what are you doing heather
um anyway this is gorgeous and he also
made for you no no this is a
this is a historical sword from his shop
oh okay uh i want to remove it without
cutting myself
yeah indeed all right here throw that
suet into the air
yeah um yeah so you know here's the
thing this is historically
just this is historical from uh this is
i think
his first real sword it comes with a
story which i will not
butcher by attempting to tell it here um
but anyway just because some watery tart
threw a sword at you is no basis for a
system of government
however a sword like this is one you can
be truly
truly proud of um and it does have some
basis in history uh but uh anyway maybe
i will
um solicit a copy of the story and post
it for people
beautiful you know in an objection to
monty python which i rarely do
i feel like arthur and camelot were
actually a pretty
damn good system outlast yeah it
definitely had its advantages yeah um
yeah so don't slice off yeah anything
important inside and i'm also not gonna
trip on it after the podcast yeah when i
walk over there please don't
all right so artisans of all sorts
including all of these all of these
people and
and and many more um okay
last free ad all right last friend this
is a this is a weird one so
you know buckle up um so here's the
thing
okay really good tools
are important and sometimes really good
tools can get
lost in the shuffle now i'm glad this
tool
is still available when i first
encountered it
i wasn't exactly sure what its point was
and it didn't really explain itself on
the packaging you had to play with it
you have to shut up and figure out what
it is so what this is
is a obscuring the vice grip part a
crescent wrench
with vice grip action right now
here's the thing a crescent wrench that
is adjustable
is a useful thing because you can set it
to whatever size nut you need to put the
thing on but it has a defect
built into it which is that when you put
it onto
something with flats like this it has
slack in it and so it tends to mar
the nut and it doesn't hold on very much
it can slip off
and so the thing about this is by adding
the vice grip action this isn't the vice
grip at all
what it does is it holds the nut with no
slack
and it's reversible you just hit that
little lever and it pops off
and so the thing is if you have
used a tool like an adjustable crescent
wrench a million times you know this
defect and you don't realize that the
solution
looks like this and that it works as
well as it does in fact i have two of
these
sometimes you have two things and
they're pointed in two different
directions
this also you know it holds on right
um so there are lots of places where you
want
that uh ability to clamp and
anyway if you need one of these i would
get them they're cheap
and they're well worth having in your
shop and um
like with normal crescent wrenches they
come in different sizes and i will say
just watching you handle it
um the smaller one is better suited to
my hands i don't know i'm not
particularly small and
particularly small hands but they but
there is actually a smaller size
of this vice grip action crescent wrench
that isn't useful for everything that
the larger one is but um
it it fits uh it fits other bodies
yeah well um i'm not sure the small one
still exists in the market oh that's too
bad i think this one might be the only
one
available there is another tool that we
have two different sizes of which is
uh very useful in that way but the thing
about this
is this problem has been addressed
many many times and almost all of the
solutions are bad
right so there are lots of different
adjustable crescent wrenches there's one
with a slide here that's particularly
terrible
um right none of them really work but
this one
just happens to cut the gordy or not
by using vice grip action for something
that you know this doesn't work as a
vice grip
right it's it's not its purpose but uh
anyway
it's it's cool that it was solved and
i'm always disturbed that people don't
know about it because hanging there at
the hardware store
it doesn't immediately leap to mind what
problem it's solving
right it's not obvious what it's for so
anyway think about whether you need a
couple of those
so um in conclusion
we are today advocating for depending on
who you are
the use of book darts extent dinosaur
stores
eagle boots trail cameras
uh artisans of all sorts and uh
adjustable crescent wrenches with vice
grip locking
and we ask you to be very cautious when
engaging
comcast and the packaging associated
with costco
otherwise known as what the actual [ __ ]
costco
right yeah yeah yeah uh are
are we oh did we have a thumbnail for
this week we'd have probably don't yet
um could be the uh
the hummingbird picture i don't know
extent dinosaur
extent dinosaur indeed all right so um
are we there we're gonna do our
announcements and uh i think we're there
all right so we will as usual take a
15-minute break and then be back with a
live
q and a answering questions that you
have posed during the super chat
uh a reminder as i said at the top of
the hour this monday at 5 p.m pacific
we're gonna have a patron-only test of
our new super chat system
in which we will be i think looking at
the live chat and answering questions
that we decide in advance if we're going
to give you bad answers to good
questions or good answers to bad
questions
some combination it should be fun just
very brief
if you have other um if you're not
interested in that you may be interested
in
the uh once a month private q a at my
patreon
um join join us there at my heather
hanks patreon or brett's
patreon um where he has two long
conversations every month um usually the
first saturday and sunday of the month
this month
um not so much because it's easter but
because it's our younger son toby's
birthday
uh we have delayed tomorrow's for a week
all right so if you are
part of that conversation it will be
delayed a week we will do it next sunday
and as usual any questions you can
direct to darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com we've got some some stuff
for sale at
www.store.darkhorsepodcast.org
and our clips channel continues to put
out
uh good good clips yeah spread the word
counteract youtube's desire to uh
disappear us
spread the word like the video
and we will see you next week all right
be well everyone
you